dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fair cryptography
helps us communicate securely with
someone in the presence of third parties
we use this when we do for instance
online banking or even as mundane tasks
as reading our Gmail one of the simplest
ways of doing cryptography is using the
Caesar cipher we have a message and each
letter we shift with the same amount
okay wait what does shifting mean
shifting the letter a by one becomes B
and shifting e by one becomes F and so
on the amount of shifting doesn't have
to be exactly one it can be anything as
long as we shift all letters in the
message with the same amount if we would
run out of the alphabet for instance by
shifting the last letter Z by one we get
a the first letter back there's a
special case of Caesar ciphers that we
call rot13 that has an interesting
property it means that we shift the
entirety of the message by 13 letters
let's encrypt a message with rot13 we
obtain some gibberish okay now let's
pretend that this gibberish is again a
message that we would like to encrypt we
get the original message back why is
that since there is 26 letters in the
basic Latin alphabet we first shift by
13 then doing it again we shift by 13
letters which is a total of 26
therefore we went around the clock and
ended up where we started mathematicians
like to describe this concisely by
saying that the inverse of the rot13
function is itself if you call it again
you end up with the same message we know
the statistical probabilities of
different letters in the English
language for instance we know that the
letter E is relatively common and Z is
pretty rare if we shift our alphabet by
a fixed amount the probabilities will
remain the same only for different
letters
therefore this cipher is quite easy to
break even automatically with a computer
this is anything but secure
communication the one-time pad
encryption is one step beyond this where
we don't shift each letter with the same
amount but with different amounts this
list of numbers
to use for shifting is called a pad
because it can be written on a pad of
paper and it has to be as long as the
message itself why one time why paper no
worries we're gonna find out soon enough
if we use this technique we'll enjoy a
number of beneficial properties for
instance take a look at this example
with a one-time pad
we have two V's in the encrypted output
but the first V corresponds to an age
and the second V corresponds to a P
therefore if I see a V in the encrypted
output I have no idea which letter it
was in the input computing statistical
probabilities doesn't make any sense
here and were powerless in breaking this
so even if you can intercept this
message as a third party you have no
idea what it is about it's very easy to
prove mathematically that the
probability of the message being happy
is the very same probability as hello or
ABCDE or actually any gibberish the
one-time pad is the only known technique
that has optimal perfect secrecy meaning
that it is impossible to crack as long
as it is used correctly this is
mathematically proven it is not a
surprise that it has seen plenty of
views during the Second World War so
what does it mean to use it correctly
several things pads need to be delivered
separately from the message itself for
instance you walk up to the recipient
and give them the pad in person the
exchange of the pads is a huge problem
if you are on the internet or at war now
you must also be worried that the pad
must not be damaged if you lose just one
number the remainder of your message is
going to be completely garbled up you're
done the key in the pad needs perfectly
random numbers no shortcuts generating
perfectly random numbers is anything but
a trivial task and is subject to lots of
discussion one time pairs have actually
been broken because of this there is an
excellent episode on a well known
channel called Vsauce on what random
really means make sure to check it out
the pad has to be destroyed upon use and
should never be reused so if you do all
this you're using it correctly in the
age of the Internet it is not really
practical because you cannot send a
delivery guy with the secret pad next to
every message you send on the Internet
so in a nutshell one-time pad is great
but it is not practical for large-scale
real-time communication from afar and as
crazy as it sounds if a civilization can
find a method to do practical
communication
with perfect cryptography their
communication will look
indistinguishable from noise this is
amazing
there's tons of ongoing debates on the
fact that we're being exposed to tons of
radio signals around the earth why can
we still not find any signs of
extraterrestrial communication well
there you have the answer and this is
going to blow your mind
if practical perfect cryptography is
mathematically possible the
communication of any sufficiently
advanced civilization is
indistinguishable from noise they may be
transmitting their diabolical plans
through us this very moment and all we
would hear is white noise crazy isn't it
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time